während weite teile der welt entsetzt
sind über die kriegsverbrechen der
russischen armee in der ukraine findet
heute in frankfurt eine pro-russische
demonstration statt wie schon in den
letzten tagen in vielen anderen städten
versammeln sich hier zum beispiel am
opernplatz hunderte putin fans mit
russischen fahnen verbreiten hetze und
halten die berichterstattung in den
westlichen medien für propaganda unser
reporter peter wilke ist jetzt für uns
vor ort in frankfurt peter was erzählen
dir die prorussischen demonstranten über
ihre beweggründe
ja dieser die ganze demonstration findet
sie unter dem deckmantel statt dass man
hier gegen diskriminierung von
russischsprachigen personen in
deutschland demonstrieren möchte am ende
ist das aber hier eine plattform für
pure russische kriegspropaganda so hart
muss man es sagen so ist es denn das
haben wir von den menschen persönlich
gehört das haben die menschen uns am
mikrofon gesagten da können wir einmal
reinhören was ihr dazu
sie meinen russland kämpft gegen nazis
genau greift
russland ich ein friedliches land an für
ostern nicht gerade ein angriffskrieg in
der ukraine natürlich nicht
wir befreien zivilisten ja wir wollen
das ganz wenige zivilisten kaputt gehen
das lege die verstecken sich dort in
krankenhäuser kein wunder dass da
raketen fliegen wenn sich irgendwelche
am ehesten in
krankenhäusern
zivilfahrzeuge sich verstecken aber die
wahrheit würde doch schon nachgewiesen
dass war die russische armee mit welche
beweisen mit paar fotos kann man nichts
beweisen
[Applaus]
ja wir haben es gehört also eben pure
kriegspropaganda die wir dort zu hören
bekommen haben darunter unter anderem
der angriffskrieg der es eben ist in der
ukraine von russischer seite aus
gerechtfertigt damit dass man die
ukraine befreien würde von den nazis
außerdem und russische kriegsverbrechen
kriegsverbrechen der russischen armee
geleugnet oder angezeichnet da wurde
gesagt es wäre eine inszenierung von
seiten der ukraine dazu haben wir mit
menschen gesprochen die auch putin
befürwortet haben die das handeln von
putin den russischen präsidenten
befürwortet haben die uns außerdem
erklärt haben dass russland und die
ukraine und viele andere staaten der
ehemaligen sowjetunion doch eigentlich
zusammen gehören würden also da
befürwortet man auch gut ins plan eben
diese ehemalige sowjetunion wieder
herzustellen ja und wir sehen uns jetzt
im hintergrund diese vielen menschen mit
den russischen fahren aber auch mit
kasachischen fahren mit ungarischen
fahren die hier eben durch frankfurt
marschieren das sind für mich würde so
schätzen 350 bis 400 personen
angepöbelt und unsere berichterstattung
wie schon so oft zuvor auch behinderten
wurden wir auch kurzzeitig angegangen da
war zum glück die polizei hier vor ort
die polizei ist mit ich würde schätzen
fast ähnlich vielen kräften hier wie die
demonstranten denn eines ist klar diese
demonstration hat klare vorgaben der
krieg dafür nicht verherrlicht werden er
kriegt dafür nicht unterstützt werden
gewisse zeichen dürfen auch nicht
gezeigt werden da gab es schon eine
kontrolle von seiten der polizei und
wenn das doch passiert dann könnte diese
demonstration auch noch abgebrochen oder
auch gewaltsam von der polizei
abgebrochen werden wenn man das wort
peter kann man wirklich nur mit dem kopf
schütteln vielen dank für den moment
peter wickel live aus frankfurt